dramatische szenen an einem bahnübergang
in los angeles sind sie kunden die hier
über leben und tod entscheiden ein zug
rast jugend über die gleise auf einem
bahnübergang liegt ein abgestürztes
kleinflugzeug der pilot noch im cockpit
[Musik]
polizisten zerren den piloten mit aller
kraft und im letzten moment noch aus der
maschine nur wenige augenblicke später
kracht der zug in die abgestürzte cessna
20 minuten vor diesen dramatischen
bildern ist der pilot von einem nahen
flughafen im san fernando valley bei los
angeles gestartet der mann ist alleine
im flieger stürzt dann aus noch
unbekannten gründen auf die bahngleise
ab zum glück ist in der nähe der
absturzstelle eine polizeiwache die
beamten sind schnell vor ort und
reagieren blitzschnell
der pilot überlebt den absturz nur
leicht verletzt weil die polizisten
schnell handeln und diese entscheidenden
sekunden über leben und tod entscheiden